what's going on there citizens the reject Nation
we are going to watch today Brooklyn 99 I got 99
problems but John ain't one he is two of
them oh ladies and gentlemen leave a like
for John's problems today so we would like for
each problem specifically full length Reaction
watch alongs where you sing it with your own
copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine available for all
those awesome people who made themselves extra by
becoming a super sexy reject on our patreon page
cover a bunch of stuff exclusively over there as
well with reaction highlights and watch along is
included all right ladies and gentlemen hope
you enjoy this video leave a comment as well
anything to help grow these Brooklyn Nine-Nine
reactions because we gotta be honest it doesn't
get to a certain point soon might just have
to end up getting them got to be a lot of a
lot of honest gotta be lonest with you that's
the person who is uh abrasive towards Lawns
alrighty let's do this man
don't get me near grass boy
the food in prison was inedible all I thought
about day and night were the things I wished I
was eating anyway I thought about you a lot sex
with you just us doing sex with foreplay great
safe babe thanks unbutton your pants and take off
your shoes because there's gonna be a doink load
of sodium at Freedom Feast 2017. oh a french fry
Village after that we're gonna move our adventure
over to Cheeseburger Mountain which consists you
guessed it of turkey burgers I'm kidding it's
cheeseburgers this is kind of just stuffing you
can avoid that but oh and finally we have a big
old Passover brisket cause you know I love my mom
if you at all take a seat while I make a toast and
the matzah you're gonna get sick to freedom
to you and most importantly to orange drink
and sex with Amy sorry should have said that last
part it's okay there's nothing wrong with sex with
Amy I imagine it's quite fun the funnest no funner
sex of the rest of the episode they're bloated I'm
ready for a case so what do you got a murder a sui
a murder Suey they often follow one another well
you can't work a case yet you've been assigned to
desktop please don't make me sit behind a desk all
day that's worse than prison no it's not prison
real bad look I'm ready I'm the same old Jake I
don't know why you have an issue with this Rosa
was happy to comply what if she jumped off a cliff
if Rosa were to jump off a cliff she would have
done her due diligence regarding the height of the
water and the angle of Entry so yes if
you see Rosa jump off a cliff by all means
babe you forgot your lunch
at home how was Argentina
it's kind of boring actually although
one funny thing did happen to me
you and I have a different idea about what
a funny thing is right anyway how's your
Boogie something's wrong he's acting weird
other than normal yes he's not telling me
something well you guys did spend several
months apart maybe it's all in your head oh
[__] be crazy is that what you're saying
I would never say that not cool Terry my
relationship's in trouble Terry loves women
women be sane [Laughter] on it join us Jake
you know you want to we're going to wing [__]
going crazy over here man the only
worthwhile thing I've done today was
take a BuzzFeed quiz about what
kind of onion I am hmm Vidalia
tell me what you're working on huh before the
stapling starts again please please I don't
know if I should I need this man just
give me a little taste grand larceny no
who got robbed sneaker story they hope you die
oh that was way too harsh there's gotta be a way
to fix it and figure it out are you serious yes
throw on your file all over the place Charles
really immature you're right I'll go clean it
up yeah he's cheating on me no I found
this credit card statement there's a
charge for a restaurant called La Palapa two
entrees one flan one plus one flan one flan
I wasted a year until interrogate them
that's what I'm holding behind my back
before we begin what are the parameters
of the guessing game how many guesses do I get
is there a time forget it you ruin everything
I can get off of desk duty if at field
evaluation performed by a member of the
municipal police training Council that's right
loophole high five ah loop hole loop hole Loop
I choose the evaluator and I choose Me Bring it
on I will good good you're good but I'm better and
I'm gonna Ace this thing before you can even oh
wait wait what are you writing now write something
good write something right so good write something
good write something good we're just gonna write
something just stop ready where's goodly really
just stop writing stop right I must have been good
all he took was a shipment of thousand dollar
limited edition wheezies designed by wheezies
what are evaluating pants they have a
deep bottom pocket for my notepad and
they don't crease which is a must given
how much I squat during an evaluation
okay there were no witnesses to the crime
which is weird since there was a long line
of sneaker heads right outside the window and
you're actually squatting just uh ignore me
there's a security camera across the
street we didn't see before I have a
feeling our answers are in that footage Squad five
I confronted pimento about
La Palapa and he lied to me
I can't lend you Department equipment
for personal use a Hitchcock you have
any surveillance equipment Rosa can borrow
you mean my creep cap no prob got another
one in the car see Amy that's what her
real friend looks like oh it's [__]
does it show everything sorry not sorry it was
a gift from my deceased father a pencil your dad
gave pretty bad gifts all my dad ever gave me was
abandonment issues so potato tomato the line moves
down everyone except for that blue pup tent which
is interesting oh my boy's got a hunch she's got
Bunches of hunches I believe all they cared about
was the placement of their tent which was right
over this manhole cover it's the sneaker store
stock room whoa how does he do it folks it was
a team effort Boyle humble five You Know It uh
I couldn't possibly what do you want how's the
pimento Stakeout going has he done anything
suspicious yet no just regular Memento stuff
we went to lunch at La Palapa and we shared the
blonde oh so you two are boning now no no the
blood's huge mental just walked up to a woman a
female woman Rosa sister they just kissed oh no
so what's this about a giant blonde thank you
Morris Richmond yes and are those wheezies yes
well done Peralta thank you
but it wasn't me it was Steph
the wheezies [Music] come on man I'm innocent
sure you are buddy we all know you did it [Music]
Charleston we arrested the wrong
guy what Morris Richmond didn't
do it we have to fix this right now
I'll wait for you to not be naked
we arrested the wrong guy what about the pup tent
and the manhole and he was wearing wheezies maybe
his friend gave them to him just like he said we
have no physical evidence tying into the stock
room plus where are the rest of the sneakers
who's the friend ah those are our stolen shoes
her name is Jenny McFadden she moves her merch
out of the back of a bodega on Willoughby cool
all right one problem if we go to the bodega
looking like detectives well spooker oh costumes
I know about your mistress I know about La
Palapa I know about the plan babe wait oh
I've been waiting I waited all night to do this
we're done it's over what no that woman's name
is Senora Reyes she's my Spanish teacher
estoy aprendiendo espanol para impression
Adrian I'm so sorry you must be so mad
at me are you kidding jealousy is like
the hottest emotion let's do this okay let's do it
Go kids we're looking to score some
kicks you know where we can find
some yeah the mall the mall what do we
look like Jay and Silent Bob [Laughter]
tell me what her favorite shoe
is old school Impala All-Stars
okay I believe that worked I
just guessed the coolest shoe
I knew when I was right nope he's running away
got me where is Jenny McFadden
that's a cover for the dude who
steals the shoes his name is Morris
Richmond he'll definitely pass your
evaluation now yeah the only thing
is you let Morris Richmond go oh no
oh what were you thinking look when we
arrested Richmond and he said he didn't do it
it's just feels a lot harder for me
to put another human being in prison
After experiencing it myself oh wow
the truth is I'm not the old me yet
damn poignant anyways I'm
gonna go cry in the room please
last night when I ended things with Adrian
I had this huge feeling of relief I need an
excuse to end things no I don't know what to
do I think you do know what to do thanks Amy
no I have no idea what she's gonna do but
that's the safest way to give Rosa advice yep
we agree that if you couldn't keep it together you
couldn't be a part of this I'll be good we went
through your case File and everything we needed
was there and an address in Queens that he used
as a safe house the two seven just picked him up
Tom tell them now yeah I can't be here [Laughter]
prison has made you more cautious yeah but
what if I'm too cautious now I mean I used
to see everything as black and white
and now it's looking real gray to me
so you passed your evaluation you can go back in
the field I think I should ride the desk for a
few more weeks I respect that you're gonna regret
that decision thank you for understanding yeah oh
look oh boy here's your blood back oh well in that
case I guess you should have your blood back too
what how did you get this you know I might want
a couple minutes up here alone just to kind of
process this you know do it what so how'd
it go it actually went surprisingly well
[Applause]
honestly this is the best I
could have asked for not a doctor
oh damn man I love pimentos I feel like
that came out of nowhere no and then why
would you even need to write them out it was
perfect yeah with the [__] they were perfect
what happened I mean he could still come back
maybe but I don't know I've learned to not expect
that from episodes that I like that I think uh
I thought it was like playing on the fact of you
know Rosa with the kind of personality she has of
still having a difficult time letting people in it
she feels more comfortable being a loner that was
an opportunity for that that she still has more
to grow in and being in a relationship I thought
it was like going that direction yeah yeah like
what the [__] Witnesses bummers yeah yeah he was
unexpected that's that's the best are you bro you
broke up with us now yeah I loved him he was such
a great addition yeah is he not liked on the show
or something what's going on here there's some
other conversation here that we're totally missing
out because I thought it was perfect do we only
attract the Adrian pimento fans out of all the
b99 followers yeah is there something that was not
to like is he sure for such a long time yeah and I
mean you know the way that they've orchestrated
his character over time it just made sense that
he would just Bop in once in a while and it's
a nice surprise and yeah it just doesn't seem
like it needed uh while he was learning Spanish
to impress her I know to impress her dad I don't
know I mean maybe this will come back but at the
same time it just it just feels pretty finite
that's a bummer real sad I thought that was it
was really strong uh but no this is a really great
episode it was a really funny episode and they
they had me going to with the I like the way the
twists and turns happened with um Peralta where
it where it did come down to the reveal of how
prison really has changed him there's not a lot
of times they go through these arcs and especially
like a sitcom off Dodge Brooklyn 99 where the
residual effect of some Journey that they went on
be played for last for an episode or doesn't
really have a lasting impact right and this had a
a more real take on what might
happen with a guy like Peralta
I mean I like the I like these sentiment
I have a publicist calling me right now
um I like the sentiment that
is always a bit of anxiety
um I like I do like the sentiment that you gotta
pick up my thoughts Sir John what we're talking
about uh the sentiment about Jake you know not
feeling ready and being very affected by his
time in prison and seeing the world oh yeah
yeah great I thought it was um I like the way
that moment was played where he was saying that
he seen things black and white side because I'm
here like shaking my head like but the I couldn't
quite tell in that moment if the if the show meant
for that to be funny yeah because they play it so
Earnest yeah with it still kind of like dramatic
handheld looked at Brooklyn Nine-Nine sometimes
does when they're having a more serious scene
uh I think there's a humor to it though just just
because his idea of like the ideal cop fatalities
you gotta see things black and white and be
certain about everything yeah you know which
is a bit of a naive POV especially now yeah um
so yeah I I did like the I really did respect
how they managed to link it to an actual Arc
about oh this is evaluate it all stems from
you know doing an evaluation and it is like
self-reflective of what he goes through and
he has to mature and the lessons he has to learn
there and I thought that was actually quite strong
I I was I was impressed with that because
like the episodes the Dual storylines are
both of what they are ex experiencing posts
being released from prison um both Rota and
and December both Peralta and Rosa so I thought
this was really strong this is really strong and
the Terry bit so it was interesting what the
Terry bit was that I didn't find it funny when
they cut to the flashback in Japan but everything
proceeding yeah when they got brought up was funny
the lasting effects of that on him you're just
like laughing at a Japanese yeah that's really
funny yeah yeah and I and I liked um it like you
know sometimes you'll have subplots where you get
a bunch of you know a few different characters
lumped together and and I thought this was one
where like all three of them in that plot line
made a lot of sense like you know even on the
the Peralta story lines mostly him and Holt and
Boyles is along for the humor of it all but in
the Amy and Rosa and Terry bit like I like that
idea of like I was helping feed into this for you
and and you know we've both been through this you
know I've been through the experience you think
you're going through the experience and together
we sort of convoluted our own worst case scenario
and uh and yeah I thought that was a nice thing
plus you get a you get a nice little involvement
for Hitchcock and Scully in their creep kit yeah
that's true so like every every character even
in the small appearance is like that you know had
a lot of flavor and uh and yeah I thought it was
like nicely rounded to go from like professional
plot to personal plot in a way that made sense
for the both of them yeah especially like the
Rose's time in prison doesn't come up a lot in
the text of the dialogue but you know it is one
of those things where yeah like after being gone
for so long and having him go down to Argentina
because of all his craziness you know like yeah
I thought this was a nice sort of recuperating of
life after person yeah and uh and yeah just like
everybody was on and everyone's like everybody at
some point made me laugh everyone's like comedic
timing was good but also the serious things or
the more thoughtful things felt appropriate and
not to preach your shoehorned or anything like
that and like you can see it coming that like
oh yeah him having this realization will lead to
him passing the evaluation but I thought the way
they handed that too and the whole thing with
the guy with with him like they had him play
that well enough to where you're like oh maybe he
is innocent and then you can anticipate like they
use the format kind of against you for subversion
in that moment because you're like okay he's gonna
wake up in the middle of the night and be like
the guy's got to be innocent and then he's not
and I thought that was a nice kind of way to do
that too yeah and I did notice there was a hint
of a moment in the they did capture it in the
scene when he says I'm innocent and my friends
the Andy Samberg does have this brief little look
like they don't do a close-up on him they don't
try to milk the moment whatsoever but it was
like a little hint of a moment before he died
but they didn't they didn't capture
that in the performance so yeah I
thought that was a really well
done episode it was really funny
um yeah guys what'd you think about it leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like helps out the video and hey we will
catch you all that is so thank you so much